let's see what's your overall overall
the film what parts work for you and
what parts didn't and what rating would
you give the film when I already gave it
a rating of really kind of answer
doesn't think over the course of this
this video I thought it was a great
movie for what it was it was fantastic i
really enjoyed it and and i would highly
suggest that people go see it do you
think Hugh Jackman is getting old to
play the role of Wolverine yeah Hugh
Jackman he's a great Wolverine don't get
me wrong he's taller than Wolverine is
really supposed to be and he's not
nearly as bulky as Wolverine is supposed
to be but but he plays a great Wolverine
in terms of the character in terms of
his spurts of violence and his rage and
his a really kind of devil-may-care
attitude I think that Hugh Jackman is a
is a great Wolverine character not to
mention that he was absolutely ripped
for this movie God Nevin I think I got
in great shape for this role let's see I
got a question Rob now that Wolverines
mine instead of Kitty's mind was sent
back to the past and made a disaster of
getting getting things even more worse
for the x-men and other characters
involved in the Marvel Universe in the
comics what news stories details and
important facts are in store for them
and the rest of the universe including
the Avengers because the issue in this
coming okay the one thing you guys need
to bear in mind is you're going to have
to separate the x-men movies from the
Avengers just because there are two
different franchises what goes on in the
Avengers has nothing to do with what
goes on an excellent they're totally
different now if what you're doing is
asking about the comics that this comic
came out a long time ago and so anyway
imma fication is this could have had for
the for the the Avengers and Marvel
Comics would have already played out by
now at this point it doesn't really have
any impact so you know there really
isn't anything going on here in terms of
things kind of going crazy I mean we see
some stuff happened like Rachel summers
is time displaced stuff like that but
for the most part there really aren't
any major ramifications of the days of
future past on the main time stream
let's see as this is an alternate
universe Days of Future past what
happened in the universe that Wolverine
appears at the end
what alternate universe is that I'm not
really sure how you're asking what
universe is the wolf's rain appears in
the end if you're talking about when he
says that he woke up from drowning and
he has the medal and everything sticking
out of him and he wakes up and he's
going through the Xavier mansion and he
sees Professor Xavier and everything
that's the mainstream Marvel Universe
that is the main main continuity that's
the earth-616 Marvel Universe it's not
alternate that's the main timeline and
there's a dog barking outside my house
my neighbors have an obnoxious dog but
let's see spoilers why do you think will
rain couldn't remember anything after he
drowned also do you think it's claws
we're still bone at the end since
mystique took over bill striker during
the during his rescue other than that I
truly like this movie and also love your
pants I appreciate that alright so
here's the deal as I understand it the
claw oh I don't think he showed his
claws when he woke up not that I'm aware
of when he woke up and he was walking
through the Xavier mansion I don't
remember him showing his claws so to my
knowledge he still has adamantium I mean
because again you know keep in mind that
the events of x-men 1 and X been to
happened and so in those movies we saw
he had adamantium claws so to my
knowledge he still has adamantium and so
William Stryker did perform the
experiment on him and he was part of the
Weapon X program and adamantium was
bonded to his bones so I don't really
see where this would change at all I
guess I hope I'm answering that
correctly I don't really see where this
would differentiate were you know he
wouldn't have adamantium I mean I don't
see how that would how that would happen
let's see was what does that say oh yeah
it was a clip at the end of the movie
for POC
yes that was for that was for apocalypse
did you like how wolf's rain went into
the past in the movie while kitty pryde
did in the comic and I mean I answer
this already but no i didn't i liked i
thought that ellen page was a great
Kitty Pryde and I think she should have
been the one to go back into the college
so I think or go back in the in the film
I think that it should have been like
Xavier the center mind of the past or
something like that do you think the
character in the opening shot with a
scar was a nod to the character cable
know you I don't think it was a nod to
cable do you think the movie did justice
to the comic book yeah I mean I
relatively speaking you know because the
one thing you gotta bear in mind here is
that when Fox makes a movie about Marvel
characters when they make a movie about
the x-men they have to make the movie in
such a way that one people who don't
know anything about the x-men can watch
the movie and know exactly what's going
on and to it's got to be entertaining
and it's got to include elements of the
comic so that people who know about the
comic you know can appreciate it and so
that when it's called x-men days of
future past that it's actually about the
days of future past so Neil to me I
think I think they did a great job I
think they did a really good job you
know staying true to the comics based on
the idea of having to create the comic
based movie in a way to where it could
appeal to people who had never read the
comic let's see what mutants or mutates
do you want to see in the following
x-men movies other than Deadpool because
everyone everyone wants to see if
everyone wants to see Deadpool there's a
few characters I'd like to see you know
I'd like to see the Fantastic Four
crossover with the x-men I think that'd
be a really cool movie you know I would
like to see more of gambit I would like
to see you know a more violent version
of Sabretooth you know i'd like to see
daikin the son of wolverine i would like
to see more mctaggart as the actual
mutant genetic researcher as opposed to
an FBI agent you know I'd like to see
the Stepford cuckoos the daughters of
emma frost you know I would like to see
Jean Grey as the Phoenix force proper I
would like to see the Hellfire Club you
know there's a lot of characters I'd
love to see in any of the M upcoming
x-men films now whether we'll actually
see them or not I don't really
no especially when he saw getting into
the territory of the Hellfire Club and
emma frost but she has children and so
on and so forth do you like the x-men
movie to be about the past young magni
on Xavier or future Picard and Gandalf I
like the past i really think the james
mcavoy and michael fassbender played
great characters i really enjoy them but
there's something to be said about the
chemistry that goes on between Patrick
Stewart and Ian McKellen because they
are well established actors and they
know exactly what they're doing and they
have really really good roles together
that's why I thought this movie was so
good because you saw interactions
between Michael Fassbender and james
mcavoy and then you got to kind of
compare and contrast that but you know
with the interactions between Patrick
Stewart and Ian McKellen and I thought
that it was actually done really really
well I think that that both groups were
able to play their characters great but
i think that at the end of the day
Patrick Stewart and Ian McKellen come
out on top in terms of their betrayal of
Charles Xavier and Magneto do you think
the skull of which should have been seen
they hinted her quick not really I don't
think it would have been a good idea for
them them to include her the reason why
is because it would have confused the
life out of people people would have
looked at that and they would have been
like oh my god you know I mean which
Scarlet Witch is right is that the x-men
days of future past Scarlet Witch is it
the Avengers grunt of which in addition
you know I guess maybe would have been a
tip of the hat tip of the hat to people
but there really wouldn't have been any
reason to show the Scarlet Witch except
to show us that she's a Scarlet Witch I
mean she it really would have served a
purpose we just kind of been like hey
you know Scarlet Witch and then people
would have said hey yeah it's a Scarlet
Witch but that really would have been
that would have been in it I mean that
would have been all there was to it they
really wouldn't be much to it than that
let's see who was the person in the end
credits what fixed the holes that other
people complain about the other movies
okay so we answer that question already
I haven't seen it yet so tell me if it's
better than or equal to what were worse
than the Avengers and the dark knight
um it's better than that well I don't
know mmm no it's not better than either
of those movies the event well the
Avengers was a great movie in terms of
action but it didn't really have any
character depth because the characters
were already established the movie was
designed to be an action movie because
we had the backstory so pretty much all
the characters so we didn't need to go
in any real care to development because
they were already developed the dark
knight of course was one of the greatest
comic movies ever made so no I'd say
it's not better than either of those
movies let's see do you think the
relationships between Magneto and
Quicksilver his son should have been
stated in the movie yeah I think so
because that kind of thing I think is a
tip of the hat to fans and people kind
of know what's going on so that if
Marvel mentions later I'm sorry if a fox
comes out with a movie later on and
they're talking about Magneto and
Quicksilver people will know what the
world is going on because I'll have this
in the back of their heads that okay
there's there's you know most likely
some kind of father-son relationship
between Magneto and Quicksilver even
though it's not like you know magneto
showed up and said hey I'm your I'm your
dad you know I you know banged your mom
and you and Scarlet Witch of the result
you know they didn't really say that but
you know we pretty much I mean those of
us who are Marvel comic fans you know
you guys and me we know that their
father and son and people who don't know
that and watching a movie are going to
have in the back of their head so
there's some kind of a relationship
between the two of them going on there
so what do you think about the Sentinels
do you do they do the comics justice
they reminded me of running a little or
a lot to the destroyer from Thor we
already talked about that but yeah they
did the comics justice they did a really
good job with the symbols all right so
this is the last question hey Rob can
you do a spider-man video explaining all
his incarnations oh that's just a
request for spider-man okay um so yeah
you know overall you know I thought the
movie was really really good it was
really enjoyable um you know if you're
on the fence about it go see it don't
don't you know go by go by taking go see
it because it was a great movie it was
really enjoyable it was
interesting was really exciting and it
is by far the best x-men movie that's
been released which in my mind actually
isn't very hard to beat with the
exception of x-men first class but but
it was a great movie it was a great
story and it was a great great
experience so with that being said I
hope you guys enjoyed this QA I'm sorry
for again you know if it was a little
bit bumpy I haven't really done this
kind of thing before but let me know if
you guys if you guys like this kind of
format you know because if you do then
with future movies will do the same
thing will just kind of keep this trend
going when we talk about movies whenever
they come out so we're that being said I
will catch you guys later peace